the cdc has just released some great
news in the fight against kovid
72 000 americans have undied of covid
19.
now i am certain these people did not
come back to life
and i'm pretty sure that these people
never died in the first place but the
one thing that i now know for sure
is that they did not die of covid
last week
without really much of any explanation
the cdc lowered the total covid death
count
by a lot not just by a few people stray
numbers here or there they lowered it by
more than 72 000
that includes around 24
of pediatric deaths
when asked how they got the count so
incredibly wrong
the agency blamed the algorithm
they said oopsie daisy a coding logic
error
caused the artificially high number
now if you had suggested
if you had maybe just raised the
possibility that possibly the official
covid death numbers were being
exaggerated over the past two years
you would have been accused of spreading
dangerous misinformation you could have
been kicked off of social media kicked
out of the public square you would have
been called a danger to society you
would have been called a murderer
you would have been blamed for other
people's deaths you would have been
right
but
that wouldn't have mattered because the
definition of misinformation today
according to big tech and even our
government is so broad
that it even includes true information
if that information is inconvenient to
the political goals of our ruling class
i'm so glad that you liked that clip i
did as well if you want to get all of
the episodes you got to subscribe ring
that bell head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play great place
to subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review and also head
on over to dailywire.com check out our
new three-part docu-series fouchy
unmasked you will get the true
never-before-seen story of dr fauci's
rise to power and maybe how to stop it
from rising to power again we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you